do you love watching people climb up
buildings and throw themselves off of
them in cool ways if you do these lesser
known parkour action movies are not to
be missed Frenchman David Bell the
founding father of Parkour brought
together a group of like-minded
physically fit people and taught them L
metha natural or natural movement B saw
parkour as a solid way to train but some
of his friends thought it needed more
flare this led to the development of
free running a parkour offshoot that
includes flips and fancy tricks the
these differences of opinion LED Bell to
split from the group which would become
known as yamakasi a Congo Le word
meaning strong in one's person in 1998
the yamakasi got their big break after
catching the imagination of Luke bassan
who saw their highflying Antics on a TV
news report the French filmmaker cast
them as ninjas in the film taxi 2 then
decided to write a full screen play
based on the team released in 2001 y
Makari became the first genuine parkour
movie and this thrilling action sequel
quences still stand up today the movie
follows the team as they attempt to
raise money for a sick boy who needs a
new heart 9-year-old Jamal suffered a
cardiac arrest after falling from a tree
and a shady surgeon is trying to rip the
boy's mother off when the yamakasi find
out they start hitting the houses of the
hospital's board of directors hoping to
put enough cash together to save the kid
Taylor lner was a big name in Hollywood
when his New York set parkour action
flick tracers started shooting in 2013
the former Twilight star plays cam a
bike messenger in heaps of debt with
increasingly impatient gangsters he's
living out of a rented garage and
struggling to keep his head above water
when a chance encounter with highflying
beauty Nikki sends him tumbling head
first into a world of crime and free
running Nikki is part of a group that
uses parkour to pull off Heights around
the city and Kamas to learn the ropes
fast if he wants to join that's the
great thing about parkour my friend
there are no rules obviously lner had to
be in top shape for the role and he
ended up doing all his own stunt he Tau
Entertainment Weekly it was actually
quite surprising to me I did extensive
training in LA with the best people in
parkour but there were some pretty
insane stunts and I think they just
about let me do everything L's
physicality and commitment made for some
impressive action sequences but the film
failed to find an audience it didn't
come out until 2015 when Twilight Mania
was fading however some critics were
able to appreciate tracers for what it
is an often exhilarating love letter to
the Big Apple the New York Times wrote
in its review you the film shows love
not just for stunts but for the dynamic
surfaces of the
city The Chronicles of nania star
William Mosley leavs the line in 2013's
run a film about a teenage parkour
Enthusiast who gets talked into becoming
a cat burglar by his old man Petty crook
Mike and his son Daniel travel from City
to City hitting jewelry stores and porn
shops they've been avoiding returning to
New York City on account of Daniel's mob
boss Uncle who blames Mike for the death
of his sister but it looks like they run
out of other play places to go when they
return Daniel quickly Falls in with the
city's free running crowd and he starts
to question his allegiance to his father
self
expression moving through your
environment freeing your body rum was a
labor of love for R to director mon baji
who decided to quit his managing job and
began working on a movie about parkour
after falling in love with her there was
some Buzz about the script and baji won
the Milan International Film festivals
Award for best screenplay so why hasn't
anyone heard of the film critics weren't
too fond of the other aspects of run
especially its ending as film intuition
wrote in its review ignoring the
prospect of what might have been a far
better payoff for the subject matter
involving a parkour contest that's
mentioned and then immediately discarded
run instead takes a gangster B movie
shortcuts in its final act that doesn't
mean run isn't worth your time though
the review continued parkour enthusiasts
will still want to give run a spin since
so few representations of what they do
have made their way to the Silver Screen
David Bard parted ways with the yamakasi
by the time Luke bassan wrote the film
of the same name but bassan would go on
to work with paror Pioneer in a later
project the director co-wrote and
produced 2004's District 13 a frenetic
French actioner that takes place in an
area of Paris that's been overrun by
crime it's become so bad that Parisian
authorities have wed the district off
from the rest of the city leaving the
poor inhabitants defend for themselves
when a government bomb is smuggled into
the slums Leo team up with undercover
cop Damen to find it uncovering a
Sinister plot by the ruling class in the
process helmed by Pierre Morel who would
go on to direct to the omn in Taken
District 13 was well received in France
and the US well most acknowledged that
the plot wasn't exactly groundbreaking
the stunning action sequences more than
made up for it in a glowing review The
New York Times waxed lyrical about the
athleticism and Artistry on show
throughout saying parkour isn't part for
the course movie Mayhem but a gorgeous
League choreograph gymnastics of pain
that elevates District 13 over the
impossible missions and last stands of
the season the vast majority of critics
agree that District 13 is worth a watch
this White Knuckle roller coaster ride
holds an impressive 80% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes certified
fresh the 2009 sequel to District 13
brought gravity defying Stars David Bell
and serial Rafa Ellie back together for
another Thrill Ride Through dystopian
Paris District 13 ultimatum sees Our
Heroes continue their efforts to bring
down the Walls surrounding the slums and
rid the area of drug dealers for good
now there's mass and rest after two
police officers turn up dead in the
district but lito and Damien soon
discover that it's a frame job corrupt
government agents plan to blow up the
five tower blocks at the center of the
district and replace them with luxury
apartment ultimatum isn't too dissimilar
to the First District 13 in terms of
Setter but the action is definitely
taken up a notch while the original
concentrated largely on Bell's parkour
Luke bason wanted to make sure to make
the most of Rafa Ellie's martial arts
skills this time around both men pull
off multiple physically impressive Feats
during the movie's 106 minute runtime
Which flies by in what feels like an
instant like its predecessor District 13
ultimatum is certified fresh and rotten
tomatoes with a 74%
rating Paris is swapped out for Detroit
in 2014's Brick Mansions the American
remake of District 13 luk basan and
David Bell were once again involved but
sirel rafaeli was replaced by Paul
Walker in what would end up being his
penultimate movie appearance it was a
move B approved of when one fan
complained about the change on Twitter
Bell defended the decision tweeting
personally I like very much the work
Paul Walker has done the film will be a
new experience for me and I look forward
to working with him as is usually the
case with Hollywood remakes of foreign
films Rick manions didn't live up to the
original there isn't as much
breathtaking parkour is District 13 and
Paul Walker doesn't match up to raphaeli
in terms of combat ability but there's
an undeniable Chemistry Between the two
leads Bell told we got this covered when
we first met we sort of looked each
other up and size each other up but from
the very first shot the shells broke and
we realized that we actually really like
each other got a plan kick his ass don't
get
squashed when Daniel Craig's James Bond
chases a Nimble terrorist across the
rooftops of Madagascar and Casino Royale
that's no ordinary stum man he's
pursuing B maker malaka is played by
Sebastian fukan an old friend of David
and one of Park's earliest practitioners
when Bell and fukan came to an impass
over the future of their passion the
latter moved to the United Kingdom and
started calling the activity free
running instead it was in northern
England that the Frenchman got the
chance to Showcase his vision for free
running by co-starring in the action
film the tournament invited director
Scott man's Universe a society of Rich
folks gather the best assassins in the
world for a big shootout every 7 years
The Killers all descend on a single town
and the last one standing walks away
with a cool $10 million Ving Rams Robert
Carlile and Liam Cunningham or feature
but when it comes to the action it's
fukan who truly impresses the freerunner
flowing moves work perfectly with the
Breakneck pace of the movie often
distracting viewers from some of its
unfortunate narrative shortcomings as
Rob Hunter said in his review for film
School rejects Sebastian fuk kan's leap
onto a moving bus is pretty sweet and
while I don't pretend to understand the
motivation behind some of his more
extraneous parkour moves I have to admit
I'm entertained watching them
the freerunner was made on a much lower
budget than most action films and it
definitely shows still there's no
denying that the parkour on display is
outstanding Lawrence Silverstein's film
follows Ryan as he races across
Cleveland with an explosive collar
strapped around his neck he's one of
eight freerunners selected to take part
in a contest in which the winner gets $1
million and the losers die as soon as
one participant crosses the Finish Line
the remaining colors detonate Shady
businessman watch the action and fold
from afar placing bets on the outcome
ridiculous maybe worth watching if you
love inventive parkour and crazy stunts
absolutely movie Mavericks declared in
its review freerunner is Fast and
Furious without the cars International
Free Running Champion Ryan Doyle
appeared in the film and was also in
charge of choreography but some of his
work was sadly undone in post-production
some shots in Free Runner seem likely
end far too early but the movie is worth
checking out even just for Snippets of
the incredibly impressive moves all I
know is after the race today something
just clicked yeah it's called a
concussion no it was a revelation Ang
Bach the Ty Warrior introduced Tony jar
to The Wider World in spectacular
fashion mixing the intensity of Bruce
Lee with the acrobatics of Jackie Chan
jar is mesmerizing a humble mu Thai
Master Ting who lives in a rural Village
in Thailand when thugs from Bangkok
decapitate The Village's prized Buddha
statue and steal its head Ting decides
to follow them and when he discovers
that the mob has it in their possession
he throws him self head first into the
Underworld the fight scenes in Ang Bach
are gritty and impeccably choreographed
but watching jar run away from fights is
just as entertaining in one of the
movie's most famous scenes Ting goes
into full free runner mode as he's
chased through the narrow Lanes of
central Bangkok by over a dozen angry
henchmen the six-minute sequence goes
from impressive to off the charts as he
out of town and performs front flips
through narrow panes of glass and
cannonballs through a ring of barbed
wire that no man his size has any right
fitting through jar turns his pursuers
into a human parkour course when
cornered using them as stepping stones
before scaling a wall and escaping the
critics absolutely loved it and if
you're an action fan you will
[Music]
see